The jogan Experience so I what I see in
the Amazon is traces of a lost science a
scientific uh a scientific
mindset can I can I show some pictures
of these gphs please we have to hook up
the magical HDM
HDMI
um and uh I'll just show I'll just show
a few slides of them
um I forget which side the HDMI is in I
think it's in that side
careful with the water
yeah got
it
okay are we are we on screen we will be
momentarily here we go yeah so so this
shows the Amazon um 6.7 million square
kilometers there's still 5 a half
million left covered by rainforest
that's bigger than the entire
subcontinent of India and hardly any
archaeology has been done and the AR
iology that is being done is fascinating
and it's particularly in the state of
acre um in in the southwest of Brazil
that we're seeing uh these extraordinary
geoglyphs now I'm here with I'm on the
on on the left there that's Marty parsen
from the University of Helsinki uh and
that is Fabio filho who's the liar
expert and that's Al ranzi who's a
Brazilian geographer and archaeologist
and we're looking at the latest Li our
discoveries and there I'm about to take
off in a playing with these two guys it
was just incredible to fly over there
I've flown over the NASCAR lines many
times but to fly over this and to see
these huge earthquakes on a scale of
hundreds of meters sitting there
often encroached on by Farms was very
very very exciting and what's the
conventional explanation for these
things there is no conventional
explanation because really it's it's
only begun to be studied I'll say you
first noticed them on a Nova flight more
than 20 years ago but it's only
relatively recently that they started to
get the funding and I want to pay
tribute to Eugene Jong uh who is a
philanthropist uh who has provided
funding for these guys to continue their
work and who's also provided funding to
the comet research group and who's also
provided funding for the DMT research
that's being done at UCSD who's what's
his name Eugene Jong he's a brilliant
brilliant guy j j n g he's a brilliant
philanthropist and he's so open-minded
and he's looking to support research in
areas that the mainstream just won't
touch amazing so we're looking at fenda
CPO here where we have an octagon with
rounded Corners um and then this is
Santa shot of the same place and you can
see what's going on you see the smoke in
the background there that's the Amazon
burning that settlers clearing the
Amazon to create more farms uh but in
the foreground we have this uh this
enormous geometrical event which is a
huge oval surrounding a square and did
they find this once they started
clearing is that when this this was
found as a result of the clearances
that's how that's how it beca
archaeologists became aware that these
things exist so before that this was
completely covered with completely
covered with rainforest it was only the
it's a sort of mixed blessing or mixed
curse if you like because the clearances
made it possible for us to know that
these things exist but the clearances
ultimately will destroy the entire
Amazon if they're allowed to continue
jaosa on the left uh a square
surrounding a circle um and here's a
couple of Sansa shots of Jack oar
you can see there's a large Square Earth
workor and a circle in it that's almost
not quite but almost like the Greek
exercise of squaring the circle it's
like geometrical exercises are taking
place here in the Amazon um and and
again a square with these
curious scallops cut into the side of it
and and and and and a circle there's
there's just so much of this uh of this
stuff to Kino absolutely giant giant
geoglyph and these things really on the
old view of the Amazon shouldn't exist
they involve enormous expenditure of
effort creating these Earthworks is is a
huge job if there were Stone if there
was a lot of stone in the Amazon I think
we'd see Stone circles on them as well
there's one place further north called
Rego Grande where there is an Earth
workor with a stone circle in it because
stone is locally available um and and so
do you think this was the base of a
structure like what is the speculation
no I don't think so I've talked to
indigenous people there who still
respect and rever them um and they say
that they were for shamanic journeying
that the that the population would
gather within them that there would be
certain areas that might be reserved for
the for the shamans for example the
square on the left those two cutout
areas top left and and and right of that
square is suggested that shamans were in
there and the rest of the population
were in the other area and they were
they were undertaking Visionary Journeys
uh perhaps using
iasa uh of course the the Amazonian
peoples are are experts in the
properties of indigenous plants and so
this is their folklore or this is their
their story yes this is the story of
indigenous indigenous people I I I
talked to an aurina um Elder uh and he
said we don't know exactly why these
places were made they were made so long
ago but we respect them we rever them
and we think that they were used by
shamans in the distant in the distant
path so they were aware of them before
the clearing everything they were of
them before the clearing and they and
they red them yes they used them and
they still have Community gatherings in
them no they weren't they weren't a base
for for structures I'm drawing attention
here to Severino kalazan this large
Square on the left there which has
coincidentally the same footprint as the
Great Pyramid of Giza it just shows you
the size of that uh that enormous earthw
work um but it's a mystery more work
more work needs to be done and much more
needs to be surveyed and thanks to lidar
that can be done non-invasively uh we
can spot these things very small teams
can go in and do a bit of excavation
there and figure out what was going on I
think the story is going to go back
further and further into the past is
there any evidence of of wood structures
like did they make buildings out of wood
back then um not that I'm not that I'm
aware of when did people start using
wood as a structure I think you can I
think you can trace wood back as a
structure hundreds of thousands of years
but but they when did they start using
it and like if you if you see like the
ancient M civilizations the what you
find in the Amazon you don't find
ancient wood structures do you I think
that's largely an artifact of the fact
that wood doesn't preserve very well
right so how do we know that there
weren't wood structures there may well
have been these there may well have been
which have which have just rotted away
and and and and gone May there may well
have been wooden structures there cuz it
kind of looks like foundations it does
it does look like foundations and it's
it's just it's just a very weird thing
but I think the main point is someone
made it someone made made it and it
involved a very large amount of
organized labor in order to make it
there had to be the will and the intent
in order to do that it's it's
interesting that the patterns are
geometrical and are they geometrical
like with the perfect length and yes
they're very they're very very
good fenda piranha and seina Kal kalazan
are both aligned to True astronomical
North that's different from Compass
North that requires astronomy you can't
you can't get True North without using
astronomy
so this tells us Not only was there a
culture that was capable of creating
large scale public projects but also
they had astronomers amongst
them wow it's uh it's it's it's a good
it's a good mystery the other thing is
the geometrical patterns are very common
uh experience in iasa Visions in in
Altered States Of Consciousness our
culture tends to despise Altered States
Of Consciousness although fortunately
that's changing but in the Amazon and
and many indigenous cultures they regard
Ed as extremely important uh that we
can't confine oursel to the the everyday
Wide Awake State of Consciousness that
requires us to interface with the
physical world there are other states of
Consciousness which are also valuable
and which bring teachings and it's just
one of those facts that most people who
drink iwasa most of the time at some
point will'll experience geometrical
Visions so there's a there's a question
is there is there a connection here
between the use of iasa and the
geometrical patterns um there there's
some a huge uh rock wall has been found
in the Colombian Amazon sad Dela lindosa
which I'm hoping to get to this year 8
km long covered in rock paintings The
Rock paintings are dated more than
12,000 years old they show uh extinct
megaper they show giant sloths which
went extinct during the younger drers
for example and they also show the kind
of entities that are seen in iasa
Visions they show the same sort of sort
of patterns the same geometric patterns
that are seen in iasa so there's a sense
that do you have any images of this
place um Sarah de la lindosa just you
connected to the yeah I don't have
images of lad DOA on here oh maybe you
could Google it um but if if uh or give
the plug I'll take the plug back I was
trying to Google it and I didn't find
anything and I might have spelled or
guessed wrong on S how do you spell
ITA La lend DOA
yeah let me just uh I got it I got it
you got it yeah you're going to have to
give him the cord real quick and then
he'll give it back to you okay there you
go um it's uh literally an an 8 kilm
cine Chapel uh in the in the Colombian
Amazon that's the other thing I
mentioned there's not a lot of rock in
the Amazon where there is Rock they used
it there's Rock paintings uh all over uh
the Amazon where rock is available these
kind of things yeah that's it um these
These are characteristic of iasa Visions
but in this case they're more than
12,000 years old now does that prove
they were using iasa 12,000 years ago no
but a very similar to like a tryptamine
vision though totally totally it does
suggest that some tryptamine was being
accessed at that time and resulting in
these in these uh Vision Visionary
images boy they shitty drawers weren't
they their drawing was terrible but bear
in mind that they're they're clambering
100t up a sheer cliff in order to
still guys do a better job ridiculous
create these paintings those the people
were so fat are those people or sea
turtles what are those
things it's really interesting to see so
this is uh 11,000 how old 12,000 12,000
plus yeah yeah 12,000 plus years old
it's interesting because if you see the
paintings that they found in that cave
in France those are 30 plus thousand
years old oh yeah there paint there's
paintings in in France if you go to
chave you're looking 36,000 years old
can you go to those J hollenstein stle
in Germany that's that amazing Warner
Herzog documentary they often have uh I
think it's was the cave of Dreams C
Dreams yeah yeah they they they often
have we're looking at Lasco hang on on
the yeah we're looking at Lasco there
the the bull painting there is
interesting they were better artists
they were they were I have to confess
theyit this artist very good if you go
Jamie if you go to the NPR the the
painting of a bull one one step left
from where you are that one um this is
this is very interesting um there has
been an argument made by uh a couple of
astronomers that what is depicted there
is the constellation of Taurus and that
uh in itself is heresy because
archaeologists who want to give
everything to the Greeks say that it was
the Greeks who invented the
constellations of the zodiac and and um
not shown why do they think that that
represents the constellation because of
the six little dots which are not I
think on the head I think they're
somewhere behind not in this picture uh
which is often how the pades are seen
they're seen actually there are seven
playes um but often to the naked eye you
see six uh and the positioning of the
pleades in relation to the constellation
of Taurus is is the basis for that
argument it could be I'm I'm not sure
it's so long since I've looked at this
but I know that there are six six dots
there uh so this cave art was going on
all around the world it's found some of
the oldest art has been found in
Indonesia you know oh here it is here's
the yeah there's the there's the there's
the playes the whole argument about the
ples um it's those dots exactly the on
the ones you pointed to above above the
back of the ball one 2 3 four five six
uh that is how the play of these are
often seen with the naked eye can you go
back to the other yeah there wow you
know that's that's it's an argument it's
not accepted by by mainstream
archaeology because of their narrative
which is that these the the discovery of
the constellations of the zodiac is
given to the Greeks or perhaps to the
Mesopotamians before the Greeks it's not
thought that any human culture could
have noticed the constellations of the
zodiac before that and that's really
absurd because the constellations of the
zodiac are on the path of the sun the
sun rises against the background of a
different constellation every month uh
and and how would the Ancients have
missed that especially since the skies
were an everpresent phenomenon to them
in a way that they are not to us right
we're cut off from the skies by light
pollution but the Ancients were not what
a fascinating concept that they knew
about the constellations 30 plus
thousand years ago yeah and I believe
they did and that and we see that again
in in gockley tee in pillar 43 in
enclosure d uh you see a constellation
that we recognize as
Sagittarius